late night eating led to increased
hunger the next day they consumed about
60 more calories and they saw a
reduction in their resting metabolic
rate I believe about five percent why
would that be the case well it's just
that like hunger is driven by hormones
and hormones are influenced by our
circadian biology typically though when
it comes to an intermittent fast most
people that do it David Sinclair and
Alex friedmans of the world will Fast
through the morning and eat later in the
day I see very few people proposing an
intermittent fasting regime which
involves eating upon waking and then
fasting from the 4 pm slot until 8 in
the morning so the data is actually
coming out suggesting that that sort of
late start followed by a late dinner is
actually the wrong approach we're
diurnal creatures so we're meant to eat
during the day I'm not saying that we
need to eat as soon as we wake up but
we're meant to eat sometimes shortly
after we arise